these two frames we rescued them from
the tower they got cleaned and then I
got them back from the company that they
retrieve them after 18 months living in
a hotel and temporary accommodation Grem
fell survivor antonia rohnke lotto is
finally in a place he calls home he was
one of the last people to be rescued
alive from the burning Grenfell Tower
you don't know who to trust who to turn
to you meet people that are trying to
you know to help and you don't know who
they are and then you know it was a
lengthy process the public response to
the ground fell fire was extraordinary
but with no single organisation
responsible for handling donations it
was hard to ensure help was reaching
those who needed it two years old a
lessons have been learned on how best to
tackle national emergencies the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge seen here alongside
victims of the grenfell fire and recent
terror attacks have launched a new
independent charity which will be the
first port of call in future disasters
I'm very pleased that the national
emergency trust now stands ready to
provide a structured organized response
to help people right across the UK in
the event of a domestic disaster we all
dread the day when you are needed but I
know that like everyone here I'm glad
that you now exists the national
emergencies trust incorporates several
charities including some which were on
the ground after grenfell and know the
importance of a coordinated response and
the absence of any kind of structure at
the time the donations of the British
public were liable to going astray for
fraudulent activities for so much not
getting to the place where it's needed
the horrific events of 2017 exposed how
unprepared the UK was in dealing with
large-scale disasters now the country is
ready if and when won't it happen again
Charlotte Lomas Sky News